câimbra na panturrilha pode ser
deficiência de quais vitaminas câimbra
que é tão comum né que pega
principalmente a panturrilha pode ser
causado por várias deficiências
nutricionais geralmente são minerais as
mais comuns são minerais e algumas
vitaminas mas os mais comuns em ordem
decrescente né de importância magnésio
potássio cálcio e sódio uma das
principais causas de câ Bras musculares
é a deficiência de Magnésio e o magnésio
ele é crucial pra função muscular e pra
função nervosa e a falta dele pode levar
espasmos e câimbras além disso a
deficiência de potássio também pode
contribuir para câimbras pois o potássio
ajuda a regular a função muscular outra
vitamina importante é a vitamina D de
dado que embora ela não seja diretamente
responsável por câimbras ela pode
influenciar a absorção de cálcio outro
mineral essencial pra saúde muscular
então a deficiência de cálcio
relacionada a deficiência de vitamina D
também pode levar espasmos musculares
além disso a vitamina B2 ela desempenha
um papel na saúde nervosa e muscular e
sua deficiência pode causar sintomas
neuromusculares incluindo as temidas
câimbras para prevenir ou aliviar as
câimbras é importante você manter uma
dieta equilibrada que seja rica em
frutas vegetais nozes sementes grãos
integrais gorduras saudáveis proteínas
Que são fontes naturais desses
nutrientes também é recomendável manter
uma hidratação adequada porque a
desidratação pode aumentar muito as
câimbras e se as câmeras foram muito
frequentes e muito severas tem que curar
médico para avaliar a necessidade de
suplementação ou tratamentos específicos
ok